hello again now I'm joined in the studio
by the shadow home secretary Dinah Abbot
hello she thanks for coming in on a
Sunday morning
now you've obviously been in the
headlines a lot over the last few weeks
and I am keen to talk about some of
those issues but first I think we should
speak about the abuse that you've
experienced and you've been in
Parliament now for 30 years the first
black woman to take your seat in
parliament you've never spoken about
this before so why be decided to speak
out now it's the level of abuse
particularly in recent weeks what we
were getting and have had for some time
is almost daily abuse being called a
[ __ ] and [ __ ] rape threats people
saying I should be hanged and it reached
a particular pitch in the last few weeks
and I thought to myself you know had I
known it would be like this 30 years on
from being elected I'd have thought
twice for running for Parliament at all
really that is actually quite shocking
and and I'd like to you know apologize
for viewers for some of the language
that we are getting listened to and have
heard and I think it is important of
course to look at some of the examples
of what we've actually seen and these
are things that have been provided by
your office and Diane Abbott the
violence and some of this language is
obviously pretty shocking and appalling
a lot of it clearly is frankly racist as
well and I think it's important to say
as well that these are the examples that
we felt we could actually show on TV
there's stuff that is even more shocking
than that in some ways and not as the
politician but as a person I mean how
does it make you feel when you read some
of that directed it yourself well first
of all it's horrible for my staff who
have to read it every day and they're a
diverse team mostly women for me first
of all it kind of does get in your head
it kind of does demoralize you and it
does even though you know it shouldn't
do it does make you doubt yourself and
when Joe Cox which unfortunately was
attacked and died of course your first
thought was virtual
Jona husband and for friends and family
and the people of bacne and span who
lost a great NP but you also thought you
know maybe this isn't all just abuse
maybe stuff can happen so since there
I've been trying to sort out the
security on my home and my staff try not
to let me walk around Hackney on my own
it's a horrible horrible world out there
it's really quite frightening and you
mentioned Jacox I remember speaking to
some other Labour female MPs he said
that after that happened their children
basically asked them to quit politics
because it's not worth it I mean the
emotional impact of it must be really
very happy the emotional impact both on
me the people that work for me and also
my family it's appalling and people
don't realize because it kind of
dehumanize you so they can call you all
these names they can say you should be
hanged or die in some horrible way and I
just think everybody not just the people
that you know tweet Facebook that stuff
but even mainstream media have to
recognize they talk about women
politicians and black politicians in a
different way what would you say then to
a young black girl or a young black boy
thinking about going into politics
because seeing some of this must be
pretty off-putting well I told him to do
it I mean in 30 years I have been able
to see change I mean I was the first
member part made a speech about Stephen
Lawrence and I with Bernie Grant was an
MP at the time on call button we took
during Lawrence to meet Jack Straw when
they were still in opposition and he
completely she completely swept him away
and as a consequence we had the
McPherson inquiry so you can make change
she can make a difference but I think
it's very very sad
that you're seeing this horrible abuse
and I actually think internet providers
could do more I think Facebook and
Twitter they're very much there are
American companies they believe in First
Amendment rights right to freedom of
speech but no one really has right to
peddle this racist and sexist abuse so
what needs to happen it do you think a
parliamentary inquiry for example into
racist and sexist abuse would help
I think that's probably a case for
parliamentary inquiry but partly to make
internet providers do more to close down
these people I mean my colleague Luciana
Berger you know that they had that in
the end they found a guy that was
directing analytic abuse at her and he
he was charged and unconvicted but
there's so many more of these people out
there and what they're doing is they're
poisoning the political debate and
they're putting off I think critically
young women from even getting involved
in the political debate online and they
must be putting off some women from
getting involved in politics and
especially one other MP about this he
suggested that there was a
radicalization if you like going on of
white men on the Internet
do you think there's a that's happening
I think it's become turbocharged when I
was a new MP if you wanted to send
racist abuse you you wrote a letter you
know in green ink usually and you got
maybe one or two those letters a week
now you can press a button and threaten
to rape somebody and the more they see
the more some of these guys see this
stuff online the more they feel
encouraged and emboldened and it's
become turbocharged and it's become
worth and it's almost as if they want to
drive some of the SATA politics is there
extra love camaraderie among other
Labour MPs do you feel that other women
empowerment have supported you I think
I've had a lot of support from Ligurian
MPs in recent weeks I'm very glad of
that I think we all have to stand
together because it is a concerted
attempt to do legitimate women in
politics first of all you marginalize or
than the most outspoken and then you
frighten other women out of saying the
same things and I think certainly
actually when I said that you were
guests on the program I think the level
of the response I received was more
strong than any other politician I've
had on this program which I thought was
and perhaps quite an interesting
illustration it's indicative I'm quite
happy to engage in political debate I'm
quite happy to engage in quite fiery
political debate but when I talk about
political debate here we're talking
about racism and sexism and abuse and
there's no there's no case for that have
you ever been tempted to quit you know
had one of those wobbles when you
thought actually it's not worth it I did
have a wobble a few
years ago I can't remember it was some
horrible press story and I rang he's
fast he went to Parliament with me 1987
and Keith was quite brisk he said Diane
you have forgotten what it took for us
to get here and he kind of gave me a
sort of emotional shake gave me some
advice but I suppose because it took so
much people forget what it was like when
I came in 87 I was the only black woman
MP you hardly ever saw even a black
admin person or secretary I remember a
few months in in 87 i was i had a friend
40 and she said to me Diane do you
realize that everybody is staring at you
as you walk around
I had them because my thing is just to
get on with a job so I'm saddened in a
way that I have to raise these issues
all these years later do you think that
labour has a bit of an issue with women
I'm asking you this because you ran for
the Labour leadership of course and on
quite a similar platform in some ways to
Jeremy Corbyn you came last when he ran
as a white man in 2015 he won in the
first round I wouldn't want to say
anything about Jeremy but I think that
some people do have an issue with women
in politics and they're not even
examining the issue they'll say things
like in response to some of the GP so
I've had recently it's like oh well
she's asked for it don't worry about her
feelings people need to examine even
cluding some of our colleagues how they
talk about how they regard women
colleagues they talk about some of your
colleagues and the example that of
course comes to mind is the brexit
secretary David Davis his text messages
about you appeared on the front pages of
the men on Sunday and saying that he
wouldn't hug you because he's not blind
how many things the kind of comments
you're talking about that but also the
fact that the mental Sunday made it a
front-page story and there were
two pages inside about it and it was all
about denigrating and belittling me this
is my point
it's not just the things that you hear
on internet it's also the way the media
acts as an echo chamber for some of them
that's interesting and were you upset by
David Davis's comments in particular was
that just the coverage I wouldn't want
to comment on David Davis at all that's
fair enough
and well thank you for being so candid
about your experiences and as an MP I'm
hoping you'll be equally candid about
some of the challenges ahead for the
Labour Party now a few weeks ago we had
the second reading of article 50 so one
of the most important parliamentary
moments where MPs got to vote on whether
brexit should go ahead at the process
should be started now Nick bol was the
Conservative MP went to that vote in a
wheelchair after receiving chemotherapy
for a tumor in his head
you missed the vote because you had a
migraine even though you'd spoken it in
debate earlier and that there were
pictures of you being in the pub the
night before what honestly happened
there what honestly happened was allowed
to go home because I had a me grain and
there were other people who missed the
vote George Osborne as the vote because
he was doing a highly-paid speech abroad
but for the third reading which is the
final vote I was there and I did vote to
trigger article 15 because the Labour
Party believes even though we campaigned
for a remain that it's very important to
take the result of the referendum
seriously so do you think that the abuse
that you got for not compared to say
George Osborne was disproportionate well
all I can say is that when it came to it
on the third reading I did virtually
article 50 you did wait to trigger
article 50 and just often made the
decision we have a look at and what you
said about the vote to a trigger article
50 which is a Tory brexit is going to be
quite disastrous if you think that
brexit is going to be disastrous
how can you look your constituents in
the eye after voting in favor of it
because I'm a member of the shadow
cabinet and I have to
abide by the collective responsibility
it's different from being a backbench MP
there's collective responsibility we
discuss this exhaustively and the view
was if you looked at the national
picture and the fact that the majority
of labour constituencies voted for
brexit then the feeling was we had to
listen as a Shadow Cabinet we had to
listen to the nation as a whole it
wasn't just a question of us as
individuals voting in line with our
constituencies so did you effectively
lose the argument then in Chadha cabinet
my view is that Chuy's ammos brexit
which puts controlling immigration above
wages above jobs above living standards
is absolutely the wrong type of brexit
but obviously the labor will continue to
campaign on access the single one United
in favor of two reason mates for exit
because those things because I abided by
a collective decision which is what you
have to do when you in the shadow
cabinet and someone else has been pretty
scathing about and Theresa modes version
of brexit is Tony Blair and who said in
the last few days that a debilitated
labour is facilitating a disastrous
brexit we already know that you agree
with Mr Blair that brexit is going to be
disastrous and and he's right isn't he
at the moment the Labour Party is
effectively the best friend of the
Conservatives not at all I mean we
actually got proportionately more of our
voters out to vote for remain than the
Conservative Party under shaping brexit
at the moment high because they do say
that up to recurse approach idea just
begun in a way we've got a really
effective grexit secretary in the shape
of pierced armor Jeremy Corbyn goes up
and down the country explaining what the
difficulties are going to be where the
Tory brexit ice especially need anything
and if you think about it there are very
few opportunities for Parliament to
actually vote and have an influence on
the deal but when you roll over there
will be more opportunities coming
forward I talked about obviously
entitled his opinion but I think that
former promises do better when they keep
out of the Westminster debate and I
don't think intervention has been
now there are two hugely important
by-elections are coming up in Copeland
and in Stoke and in some ways there
should be a formality for labour they
should win both of those by-elections
but of course there are fears that the
Labour Party could lose at least one of
them considering you've been so frank in
this interview if Labour does lose one
of those by-elections do you think that
Jeremy Corbyn should consider his
position would you have any doubts over
his leadership these are difficult
by-elections they're going to be quite
tight
we are hopeful of winning both of them
but it's really important that every
Labour supporter comes out to vote and
if we lose one we lose both I think the
party will go forward it has to go for
these are they no questions over Jeremy
Collins leadership man if he loses one
no no I mean there are people who've
been opposed to Jeremy from the
beginning I'm not one of them and I
think we have to move forward the poll
so are pretty abysmal per labour right
now and we saw this week that Jeremy
Corbyn is more unpopular than any
opposition leader in modern history at
this moment at this time after his
election are you confident that if the
polls don't improve he'll still be
leading labour into the next election
I'm confident John will lead us into
2020 and the point of other polls is you
had needing a year of a sustained
campaign against Jeremy Labor Party both
in the media and sadly a few of our MPs
I still seem to have died down now he's
having a free run at Bret's at the
moment it familiar people he's not he's
not doing it out yeah I think as we move
beyond what has been almost a year of
misrepresentation of Jeremy's position I
think if you move beyond that and the
more people get to see him and hear him
whether it's in the media or at
campaigning events I'm confident the
polls will improve if that doesn't
happen do you think then that the
succession needs to be looked at because
there are reports of course at polling
being done about other members of the
Shadow Cabinet
well that was that those reports are
really true it was polling about how to
we what's our best voice in the north I
think no I don't think we need to be
looking at the succession because I'm
confident Joan will take us into 2020
now you've dedicated your life to
championing left-wing politics finally
for the first time you've got a leader
who shares those left-wing ideals as the
leader leader at the Labor Party and at
the same time with the polar anthem to
go by the public don't really like what
you're selling I mean what does that say
about the future of the left wing ideals
that you've convinced I committed to I
won devoted my life to left-wing ideals
so I start out in my life to social
justice at home and peace abroad and I
still think those are vital issues
particularly the era of Trump and just
because something is unpopular at a
different moment in time doesn't mean to
say you should drop it when I first
became an MP the idea of gay rights the
idea of women's equality the idea of
justice for black people was wasn't
popular at all and even some Labour MPs
thought that by pushing those ideas the
London Labor Party was responsible for
us losing in 87 and actually those ideas
are now mainstream and my view but
politics is if you believe in certain
things should be prepared to campaign
for them and I've been live to see and
if you like gay rights become mainstream
middle of the road issue with a Tory
Prime Minister put into legislation on
equal marriage so I haven't given up on
my ideal it's not at all you haven't
given up on your ideals keep fighting
the fight even if the polls don't
necessarily reflect that people are
agreeing with what you're doing down a
bit thank you very much